Ngành ông Trung trên Chi bị lực lượng an ninh áp giải giãn độ về Trung Quốc sau khi bị mắt ở Cam Bu Chi
ở.
Đại chuyên hình Quốc gia Trung Quốc CCTV công bố video, ông Trung trên Chi được lươi về ngày bài tháng một
trên VEK Hẳng Hẳng không Trái Nă Sau Dân.
Trên mặc lưu Mô Dan khi được áp giải lên VEK sau đó thay sang bộ độ sang dân.
Bộ công an Trung Quốc sang nhận đã cử nắm công tác và áp giải chân từ phần nước
pang về Trung Quốc.
Chức đó, ngày sau tháng một Cam Bu Chi thường báo bắt giữ chân cùng hai công dân Trung Quốc khác
trong cuộc khổ hợp tác, chúng tội phạm xuyên Quốc gia, sau nhiều tháng phối hợp điều tra.
Chân Chi, chân Chi, xinh tại tình phúc kiến, được cấp cuốc tịch Câm Bu Chi Năm Hành Ninh không chăm mối
bốn, là người sáng lập Prince Ho Ding Group được biết đến là một trong những tập đoạn lớn và
có mạng lưới quan hệ giọc ở Cúch gia đồng nằm.
Theo cáo Bộ của Mỹ và Anh tập đoạn này chỉ là bỏ bọc trong một mạng lưỡi tội phạm
xuyên Quốc gia, liên quan đến lao động cực bất và lửa đạo trực tiến.
Tháng 4 năm hành hình cùng trong hành nằm giới trực Mỹ truy tổ chân Chi với cáo Bộ điều hành các trù tâm
lửa đạo tiến số, tị thu khoảng 1,2% bị mốt biết thoại, chỉ giá gần mấy lắm tị USD.
Nếu cuộc gia đã ablack trường phạm và điều tra các khóa động liên quan đến ông Trung này.